good afternoon good afternoon
I'm ruff I Drive
I'm mi t--'s president and I am
delighted and it's a privilege for me to
welcome you all to this important event
let me just do our microphone check do
you hear me way in the back you him
you're right
our subject today is the report called
sexual harassment of women climate
culture and consequences in academic
sciences engineering and medicine as you
would expect from a consensus report of
the National Academies it is a serious
piece of scholarship and we are
fortunate as lead authors president of
Wellesley College Paula Johnson and
Institute professor sheila widnall of
MIT are with us today I'd like to start
by offering a warm welcome to friends
and colleagues from our academic
neighbors including Wellesley and
Brandeis and a special welcome to our
guest speaker University professor Anita
Hill I also want to recognize
my only job here today was to introduce
her I also want to recognize Chancellor
Cindy Barnard Provost muddy Schmidt vice
president and general counsel Marty VIN
sensor vice president for human
resources Lauren Goff and the many
others here today who have led the way
officially and unofficially over decades
to make MIT a more equitable and
welcoming community for everyone thank
you and by all means keep going
today I'm deeply encouraged your
attendance speaks to the strong desire
to understand these issues more fully
and to keep making progress in a moment
Sheila and Paula will speak about their
findings and recommendations for now law
for just a few comments on why this
issues matters so much right here at MIT
over the last year they meet to movement
force the whole country to grasp that
sexual harassment is pervasive like all
of you I was deeply disturbed by the
revelations of misconduct elsewhere and
I must believe it also happens at MIT on
this question our community is not an
oasis of safety in fact the National
Academies report make this same point
about academic institutions in general
when it comes to sexual harassment a
community like ours presents a
particular set of risks a 24/7
environment that brings together people
across a broad range of Ages incomes and
backgrounds many of whom have power over
others the power to make being at MIT
miserable power enough to make or break
a career
the success of our community is built on
collaboration and mutual respect
sexual harassment is an act of
aggression that belittles our nerves and
controls it violates our fundamental
expectations of respect and equality and
it violates the humanity of the person
being harassed an emotive fulfilling our
mission depends on people of exceptional
talent performing at the height of their
capacities and working together to solve
the most challenging problems it's
obvious that there can be no room for
sexual harassment in that picture
last fall I wrote the community to
express those values and ideas and I
also described our efforts to fight
sexual harassment at MIT let me offer a
few updates since then we have expanded
rules regarding consensual relations
among community members across lines of
authority such as faculty and graduate
students we are assessing the
disciplinary process of or handling
sexual misconduct cases Marty Cindy mark
and Lorraine have worked to develop
enhance processes for handling sexual
harassment complaints against staff and
faculty and these recommendations are
being vetted internally and I hope that
we can start to implement them soon
because a true solution needs to include
everyone
we have also greatly expanded training
efforts online we started with students
and a week ago Marty Simeon Lorraine let
us know that when we expanded that
online training to include all paid MIT
faculty and staff the participation rate
was an outstanding 99.7% to the 9300
faculty and
laughs who took the time to complete
this program I thank you this is a
tremendous expression of this
community's commitment and values
finally to make good decisions we need
good data mine hand heart is already
conducting studies about the working on
learning environment in various
departments and next spring we will once
again conduct an in-depth survey that
will allow students to convey how they
may have experienced sexual misconduct
at MIT I'm grateful to everyone who has
worked so hard on this many fronts in
the end however the most important work
is up to all of us we need to actively
build a culture that three sexual
harassment coercion and assault as out
of bounds unthinkable unthinkable for
anyone of any age in any context gang on
the culture right matters to us here on
campus and in matters far beyond campus
to because the students we educate will
go on to launch and lead and populate
companies labs agencies institutions and
governments around the globe and they
will carry with them the professional
culture they experience at MIT finally
let me state the obvious
most harassers are men
as a result the men in our community
have a particular responsibility and
must play a particularly important role
in leading and driving the necessary
change in culture every member of our
community is valuable and harm to one is
harm to all as long as sexual harassment
and assault persist in our community we
fail to live up to our shared potential
and to fulfill our aspiration to make a
better world so I close with a challenge
that we each strive to define what we
can do to invent a better emetic
community for those who are here today
and for those who follow us tomorrow and
now is my great honor to introduce
someone whose integrity and courage 27
years ago brought sexual harassment to
the center of our national conversation
in 1991 during the confirmation hearings
for US Supreme Court nominee Clarence
Thomas Anita Hill testified that as her
supervisor at the US Department of
Education and the Equal Opportunity
Equal Employment Opportunity Commission
Clarence Thomas had sexually harassed
her for those of us who were adults at
the time professor Hills courage in
coming forward and the terrible
disrespect she endured during her
testimony and long afterward are
unforgettable until that moment sexual
harassment was a legal and academic term
in fact early work on the subject was
done here at MIT by our very own Mary
Rowe but the concept was not widely
understood today we know that sexual
harassment is pervasive that is wrong
and that the responsibility to stop it
belongs to all of us
for all that we owe a great debt of
gratitude to university professor Anita
Hill a graduate of Yale Law School she's
the author of two books including her
autobiography speaking truth to power
today she serves as the University
professor of social policy law and
women's gender and sexuality studies at
Brandeis and as fall she was selected by
some leading figures in Hollywood to
chair their new Commission on sexual
harassment and advancing equality which
aims to tackle the broad culture of
abuse and power disparity in the
entertainment industry professor Hill
spent last year as an MIT MLK scholar
she continues as an MIT research
affiliate and we are very proud to count
her as a member of our community please
join me in offering a world welcome to
university professor
Thank You professor president right for
that gracious introduction and thank all
of you for being here to hear the report
on this incredibly impressive study that
I have already begun relying on in my
not only in my own work but in my
teaching as well I'm really pleased to
be here at MIT I say I'm pleased to be
back I was here last year but I'm
especially pleased to be here for
today's program on the National
Academies consistent study report my
first experience with this study came in
late in the year of 2016 and that was at
the initial convening of this really
impressive group of people who have come
together to contribute to the work that
has resulted in the publication that
you're just about to get a glimpse of I
will tell you that you will need more
time and and actually a lot of time a
lot more time because this this report
is I would say the most comprehensive
report on sexual harassment and the
research and the recommendations that
has been published to this point and we
are of course thrilled that the
co-chairs of the study group president
Paula Johnson of Wellesley University
and your own sheila widnall
Institute professor at MIT are here to
present to us today this work actually
set me the beginning of this work set me
in good Steve for my year here at MIT in
the research laboratory of electronics
it's an MLK Fellow and I had the
pleasure of partnering with Professor
Muriel Medard and the whole her whole
laboratory actually
like I was parking with the entire lab
including our administrative assistant
Molly Kruk Oh Samson Wilcox who created
the art for our series for this poster
as well as a series of talks that we
presented to this community about title
9 but more broadly about gender and
racial inclusion in science technology
engineering and medicine so we hosted
this series and we call that the gender
race imperative because I realized that
gender inclusion was never going to be
complete unless we included in our our
thinking other identity factors as well
and our talks were focused really on
greater inclusion in stem and really not
just the greater inclusion but how do we
get there not only talking about the
problem but how do we get to a solution
now I will say when to this kid sound
immodest but it's not really immodest
because I didn't give any of their
lectures but the entire series was quite
excellent covering topics including law
of course the history of women at MIT
which was a lecture given by Bob gray
mentoring given by Institute professor
Leslie College etske
and marginalization and a lecture given
by dr. Ellen Hammond of Harvard there
were many others as well and their tie
into today's program I think will become
much more obvious as we go on for today
but I do want you to know that if you
miss the lectures they are on our
website
and you can find them at at our lead
mit.edu slash anita - hill so no topic
is more important or timely than the
topic of sexual harassment in gender
harassment throughout society we are
fortunate that the National Academy has
taken up the challenge of exploring this
extensive problem the contributions that
this volume makes goes beyond science
engineering and medicine and beyond the
academic experience this consensus
report covers the issue whether it is in
the workplace as a workplace issue
whether it's in school whether we're
talking about students or people well
into their career you will find
information that is relevant to sexual
harassment whether it whether men are
the victims women are the victims or
whether non-binary individuals are the
victims so the range of this work is
really important but it specifically
back to this setting in 2018 across the
country in universities and colleges
throughout decisions about the
enforcement of Title Knives protections
are being made even as we meet it
reminds me of a statement that was made
by Senator Birch Bayh when Title 7 or
excuse me when title 9 was first enacted
in 1972 he Aman estas that title nine
was not a panacea and what he said it is
and I will quote an important first step
in the efforts to provide for the women
of America something that is rightfully
theirs an equal chance to attend the
schools of their choice to develop the
skills they want and to apply those
skills with the knowledge that they will
have a fair chance to secure jobs of
their choice with equal pay for equal
work now what that also means it
that is that they will be able to do
their jobs in attend those schools in
environment free from harassment but
title nine really is just the start and
the report brings that out it's just the
beginning this volume if title nine is
the first step this volume is a critical
next step it provides guidance for
protecting against harassment it makes
sure that women and science engineering
and medicine are treated fairly from a
school of their choice to equal pay for
equal work and in between by eliminating
harassment women men and all individuals
have a better chance of achieving
equality viewing harassment as a
systemic problem is one of the greatest
contributions of this volume and there
are many many more that I want get into
because that's what our presenters are
here to do but I will say to all of you
who are here today whatever your
particular focus is whatever your
particular interest in this subject is
whether it's workplace harassment
harassment in the academy harassment on
the streets this volume has
recommendations it has science and it
also gives us comfort in knowing that
change is possible and so with that I
will turn the podium over to professor
widnall
now for a presentation on the volume
okay let me check that the microphone is
working can you hear me way in the back
row okay good okay before I start I
would like to introduce two people that
are here our study director Fraser
Benoit can you raise your hand she flew
all the way up from Washington DC she
was the person who kept us in track on
our report we couldn't have done it
without her and then Kate Clancy who's
from the University of Illinois and she
was a member of our committee and she is
spending this year at MIT so we're
delighted to see you okay so this is a
discussion of the report from the
National Academies of science
engineering and medicine and I want to
emphasize this word consensus report
National Academy reports have to be
based on data you can't just give
opinions you really have to have data
and it has to be firm and you have to be
able to rely on it and stand on it so
that's sort of the requirements for the
report so let me we try to push this
trying to change the slide guy now wait
a minute maybe I'm I've had it upside
down
okay I think one of the things I want to
start out with is is how did we get into
this there is a Standing Committee at
the National Academies on women in
science engineering and medicine and
that's the Standing Committee they've
been in in a place for a long time and
then every once in a while they they put
a task together and ask a subcommittee
to take up that task for a sort of
finite period of time and so they we
were tasked by the National Academies
committee to do this study and we have
Paula Johnson is the co-chair I'm the
co-chair and there's a list of our
members they were social scientists they
were scientists they were engineers they
were people from industry so it was a
very very broad committee this is the
study the statement of our task and just
to make things easy for you I've just
highlighted the first three words of
each task and you can read it if you
read the report but we're supposed to
review the research we're supposed to
examine existing information and we're
supposed to identify and analyze
possible policy strategies and practices
so that was basically our task dealing
with the influence of sexual harassment
in academia on the career advancement of
women in scientific technical and
medical work forces so that was our task
these were our sponsors we had
considerable help from our sponsors and
we met with our sponsors at the end of
our task and I would say they're Punk
sponsors were extremely pleased and want
to continue to move forward in this area
so I'm going to talk about the findings
and then my co-chair Paula will talk
about our recommendations first of all I
think it's very important to get a
definition I mean we've heard in our
opening statements several statements
about sexual harassment so I think it's
really important and I thought one of
the important things that our committee
did is give a very broad definition of
this which really encompasses a variety
of behaviors and so it's really
important to focus on those because they
really influence the climate in
University I'm focusing on universities
but it's not just the universities it's
the workforce it's the entire population
so we're interested in gender harassment
unwanted sexual attention and sexual
career corrosion
now obviously gender harassment is the
most pervasive of those and and yet in
some fundamental sense it is almost the
most important because it completely
controls the environment that's seen by
women in science engineering and
medicine so that that's really what
we're focusing on and so sexual
harassing behavior is considered illegal
when it creates a hostile environment or
when it is quid pro quo sexual
harassment this is one of the most
important figures and I'm just going to
leave this up for a little while when we
hear the word sexual harassment most
people focus on the part of the iceberg
that's out of the water and these are
clearly extremely important things
having to do with physical assault
having to do with quid pro quo
harassment but the part that is less
clear to the public is the part that's
underwater and I don't know if you can
all read this from where you're sitting
but obscene gestures offensive sexual
teasing insults women don't belong in
science women don't belong in
engineering sabotaging women's equipment
calling people by vulgar names all of
those things in some sense are below the
waterline and yet in some fundamental
sense these are the most important
definitions of sexual harassment and
these are the things that universities
really need to ensure don't happen and
so that's really I think one of our very
very important outcomes of our report is
to really emphasize these things so this
is some of our findings
that talking about ambien harassment and
gender harassment that sexual harassing
behavior can either be direct targeted
at an individual or it can be ambient it
can create unsafe uncivil unwelcome
environment and when it occurs severely
or frequently it can result in the same
level of negative professional and
psychological outcomes as can isolated
instances of serious sexual harassment
and coercion we believe that sexual
harassment is common unfortunately that
it is common in academic science
engineering medicine and that the data
and we are basing our report on
available data the data shows that 50
percent of women faculty and staff in
academia experienced sexual harassment
and here I'm talking about this very
broad definition of sexual harassment
and uncivil environment and did we had
extensive surveys of students and this
the student survey showed that between
twenty and fifty percent of students in
science engineering and medicine
experienced sexual harassment from
faculty or staff and this is some data I
mean if you can all see this but you
know some of those bars are forty
percent high they're thirty percent high
they're twenty percent high and they
deal with these various definitions of
sexual harassment gender harassment
hostility gender harassment crude
behavior and then unwanted sexual
attention and sexual career coercion
which is obviously the most serious and
we also looked at the is what I would
call intersectionality that women is of
color experience more harassment sexual
racial or ethnic or some combination
then white women do and women in color
often experience sexual harassment that
includes racial harassment and sexual
and gender minority people experience
more sexual harassment than heterosexual
women do
okay another finding is that that this
kind of behavior can impact not only the
individual person but it cannot have an
effect on bystanders and it can have an
effect on the entire research enterprise
and it can undermine women's
professional and educational attainment
and their mental and physical health it
has adverse effects that affect not only
the targets of the harassment but also
the bystanders the co-workers the
working groups in the entire
organization and the cumulative effect
of sexual harassment is significant
damage to research integrity and a
costly loss of talent in academic
sciences engineering and medicine two of
the characteristics that are most
associated with higher rates of sexual
harassment are unfortunately
male-dominated gender ratios and
leadership and an organizational climate
that communicates tolerance of sexual
harassment so we felt that
organizational climate is by far the
greatest predictor of the occurrence of
sexual harassment and ameliorating it
can prevent people from sexually
harassing others so what we are really
focusing on is the creation of a civil
welcoming safe environment for everybody
but particularly focused on you know
women's students women faculty and and I
believe that that is in some sense one
of the most important findings that we
have made to talk a little bit out the
legal system and Anita talked a little
bit about this it is not an adequate
mechanism for reducing or preventing so
so harassment we've often referred to
title- a platform not a solution its
judicial interpretation of title nine
has somehow incentivized organizations
to create policies procedures in
training on sexual harassment that
focuses on symbolic and compliance with
current law and which will help them to
avoid a liability but that's checking
the boxes and that doesn't really
influence and it doesn't really indicate
a real commitment to improve the
environment so we are focused on title 9
title seven and we we believe that they
reflect an inaccurate assumption that
the targets of sexual harassment will
always promptly report the harassment
without worrying about retaliation and
what we found was the least common
response for women is to formally report
the harassing experience and for many
this is due to an accurate perception
that they may experience retailer
retaliation or other negative outcomes
associated with their perfect person
personal and professional lives so in
some sense the price is higher for them
than it is for the perpetrator
we also made recommendations with
respect to the federal government and
professional societies many professional
societies have taken up this issue and
they have put in place meeting rules for
attending meetings and policies and
procedures and value statements that
encourage a welcome and civil
environment at professional Society
meetings and there have been quite a few
professional societies that have done
that and we believe that they do have
the potential serve to be powerful
drivers of change and so this is really
one of our most important observations
is that really it's a system-wide change
to the culture and climate in higher
education that is required to
and effectively address all three forms
of sexual harassment so we found that
changing the organizational climate
means creating a climate where sexual
harassment again this broad definition
of sexual harassment where sexual
harassment is not perceived to be
tolerated or permitted and you know I
can take you back to the iceberg and
remind you what all those little micro
things are there that are micro insults
that many people feel are not important
they are important so the
characteristics of an organization with
a permissive climate towards this kind
of behavior this kind of sexual
harassment include the following if
there's a perceived risk to victims for
a reporting harassment if there is a
lack of sanctions against in fenders and
if there's a perception that one's
complaints will not be taken seriously
these are important pieces of the
organizational climate so at this point
I'm going to stop talking about our
findings and turn the podium over to my
co-chair Paula Johnson president of
Wellesley who's going to talk about her
recommendations
Sheila thank you so much and it is truly
a pleasure to be here with you today and
I said to Anita you know we started this
before the me2 movement started and here
we are today with the news still booming
with these issues which is truly
unfortunate but I think points out the
importance of this work I want to just
recognize Evelyn Hammond who's a member
of the committee of the National
Academies of science engineering and
medicine who actually helped to charge
us with doing this report so Evelyn
thank you to you and the committee
[Music]
so I just want to say a bit about myself
before becoming the president of
Wellesley College I spent in July of
2016
I spent 31 years in academic medicine I
was a professor of medicine at Harvard
Medical School and a professor of
epidemiology at the Harvard th Chan
School of Public Health and I did work
on research focused on the discovery of
sex differences in health and disease
and translating that research into
clinical care and I do want to say it
has truly been an honor to serve on this
committee with Sheila as my co-chair and
with Kate Clancy who's here in Frayser
Boehner and the rest of my committee
members
so our report in terms of its most
important conclusions the real focus has
been on how to prevent sexual harassment
and I just want to reiterate the point
that Sheila made that a system-wide
change in the culture and climate in
higher education is required to prevent
and effectively address all three forms
of sexual harassment sexual coercion
unwanted sexual attention and gender
harassment and I want to point out that
in spite of significant attention to
this issue in recent years there's
absolutely no evidence to suggest that
current policies procedures and
approaches have resulted in a
significant reduction in sexual
harassment so it is really time to
really consider an approach that
addresses the system's cultures and
climates that enable sexual harassment
to prep to perpetuate so the top four
things that institutions can do to
prevent harassment include one to
integrate values of diversity inclusion
and respect into policies and procedures
number two is to change the
power dynamics and advisor trainee
relationships number three to support
targets of sexual harassment by
providing alternative ways to access
support services record information
about an incident and report an incident
without fear of retaliation and four to
improve transparency and accountability
to demonstrate that institutions are
investigating and holding people
accountable so what I'm going to do is
go through some top level
recommendations and then drill down on
the recommendations for institutions and
then drill down on the recommendations
for policy and federal agencies so one
to pay attention to and enact policies
on gender harassment it's important that
leaders and academic institutions and
research and training sites pay
increased attention to and enact
policies that cover gender harassment as
a means of addressing the most common
form of sexual harassment and preventing
other types of sexually harassing
behavior it is clear that in
environments where gender harassment is
allowed to grow allowed to flourish that
the other forms of sexual harassment
unwanted sexual attention as well as
sexual coercion are more likely to occur
we have to move beyond legal compliance
to address culture and climate academic
institutions research and training sites
and federal agencies should move beyond
interventions or policies that represent
basic legal compliance and that relies
solely on formal reports made by targets
three professional societies should
accelerate their efforts this is an
important area because we've seen
movement in professional societies and
we believe that they can do more
professional societies should accelerate
their efforts
to be viewed as organizations that are
helping to create culture changes that
reduce or prevent the occurrence of
sexual harassment and last consider
sexual harassment equally important as
research misconduct academic
institutions and federal agencies should
consider sexual harassment equally
important as research misconduct in term
of its effect on the integrity of
research so when we think about academic
institutions it's important too as we
think about this culture change it's
important to create a diverse inclusive
and respectful environment now that's
easy to say but what does that actually
mean academic institutions and their
leaders should take explicit steps to
achieve greater gender and racial equity
in hiring and impre motions and as a
result improve the representation of
women and a diversity at every level
academic institutions and their leaders
should take steps to foster greater
cooperation a respectful and respectful
work behavior and professionalism at the
staff faculty student and trainee levels
and should evaluate faculty and staff on
these criteria in hiring and impre
motion academic institutions should
combine anti-harassment efforts with
civility promotion programs and that
when we say civility promotion we're
really talking about programs that
foster an environment that fosters a
culture of respect and as we think about
training training should be tailored to
specific population one size does not
fit all this is an area that really
requires more evaluation but from the
data it's clear that training does need
to be tailored to specific groups
students and trainees staff
faculty and those in leadership and from
the data that we do have it's clear that
training should not be focused on
changing beliefs but on changing
behavior and there are some qualities of
training that also seemed to be
associated with improved outcomes those
are one that it's in person two that
it's a reasonable length three that
again targeted to specific audiences and
for that leadership is present and
involved in the training it makes a very
clear and strong statement second it's
important to defuse the hierarchical
power structure in the dependent
relationship between trainees and
faculty in order to reduce the risk of
sexual harassment now some of the
mechanisms that academic institutions
can consider include for example
mentoring networks or committee based
advising and really consider
departmental funding as opposed to
funding only from one principal
investigator which only enhances that
dependent relationship next we also
recommend providing support for the
targets of sexual harassment academic
institution should convey that reporting
sexual harassment is an honorable and
courageous action I'm going to say that
again it's an honorable and courageous
action regardless of whether or not a
target files a formal report academic
institutions should provide ways to
access support services such as such as
social services health care legal
services and career and professional
services they should also provide less
formal ways of recording information
about the experience and reporting the
experience particularly if the target is
not comfortable with
filing a formal report and it's
important that academic institutions
develop approaches to prevent the target
from experiencing or fearing retaliation
in academic settings and this is a
critically important one and one that as
Sheila mentioned earlier drives women or
drives targets not to report next it's
important to improve transparency and
accountability now what do we mean by
that academic institutions need to
develop and readily share clear
accessible and consistent policies on
sexual harassment and standards of
behavior they should include a range of
clearly stated appropriate and
escalating disciplinary consequences for
perpetrators found to have violated
sexual harassment policy and/or the law
disciplinary action should correspond to
the severity and frequency of the
harassment and the disciplinary action
should not be something that is often
considered a benefit for the faculty
such as reduction in teaching mode or
taking time away from campus service
responsibilities decisions regarding
disciplinary actions if indicated or
required should be made in a fair and
timely way following an investigative
process that is fair to all sides and
academic institutions should make as
transparent as possible how they're
handling reports of sexual harassment
next we have to strive for strong and
diverse leadership college and
university presidents myself included
Provost Dean's department chairs and
program directors must make the
reduction and Prevention of sexual
harassment an explicit goal of their
tenure they
publicly state that the reduction and
prevention of sexual harassment will be
among their highest priorities and they
should engage students faculty and staff
and where appropriate the local
community in their efforts and I do want
to say president rife you exemplify that
leadership thank you
and lastly it's important to make sure
that the entire academic community is
responsible for reducing and preventing
sexual harassment all members of our
nation's colleges and university
campuses including students trainees
faculty staff and administrators as well
as members of research and training
sites should assume responsibility for
promoting civil and respectful education
training and work environments and
stepping up and confronting those whose
behaviors and actions create sexually
harassing environments so next I'm going
to go through some of the
recommendations for policy makers and
federal agencies these include one
better protecting sexual harassment
claimants from retaliation second
prohibiting confidentiality settlements
settlements settlement agreements that
currently enable harasser x' to move to
another institution and conceal past
adjudications banning mandatory
arbitration clauses which by the fact of
their their arbitration means that
they're private
banning mandatory arbitration clauses
for discrimination claims allowing
lawsuits to be filed against alleged
harasser x' directly instead of or in
addition to their academic employers
requiring disclosure of results from
surveys we should consider requiring
institutions receiving federal funding
to publicly disclose results from Clint
campus climate surveys and/or a number
of sexual the number of sexual
harassment reports made to campuses we
should also consider requesting that the
National Science Foundation and the
National Institutes of Health devote
research funds to doing follow-up
analyses on the topic of sexual
harassment
in science engineering and medicine in
three to five years to determine one
whether research has shown that the
prevalence of sexual harassment is
decreased and second whether progress
has been made on implementing these
recommendations and third how do how and
where do we focus our future efforts we
also have to attend to sexual harassment
with at least the same level of
attention and resources devoted to
research misconduct they should increase
collaboration among offices that oversee
the integrity of research for example
those that cover ethics research
misconduct diversity and harassment
issues consider centralizing resources
information and expertise providing more
sources for handling complaints and
working with targets and implementing
sanctions on researchers found guilty of
sexual harassment require institutions
to report to federal agencies when
individuals on grants have been found to
have violated sexual harassment policies
or have put been put on administrative
leave related to sexual harassment this
is a policy that the National Science
Foundation has has proposed doing agency
agencies should also hold accountable
the perpetrator and the institution by
using a range of disciplinary actions
that limit the negative effects on other
grant personnel who were either the
target of the harassing behavior or
innocent bystanders and this is a very
important one in terms of not penalizing
the entire research team for example we
should also increase support for
research and evaluation on the
effectiveness of policies procedures and
training on sexual harassment and we
should also report we should also renew
and incentivize colleges and
universities for implementing policies
and programs and strategies that
research shows are more likely to and
are exceeding in reducing and preventing
sexual harassment so those are our
recommendations they are pretty broad
and but we think that they are
actionable and can actually be put into
into place in some reasonable period of
time the National Academies are actually
putting together a collaborative of
academic institutions to begin to better
understand what that implementation
looks like and how we can actually give
feet and legs to this report so thank
you
Thank You President Johnson and
professor widnall we welcome you to come
to the microphones on either of these
aisles and ask your questions of the
panel
I will take my seats and please don't be
shy I'm sure many of you do have
questions so here are the mics right
here and I welcome you to come down so
I'm David singer from political science
thanks so much for being here and
sharing your your thoughts and then
incredibly detailed and
thought-provoking study I've just a
couple of questions about that one is
that the the subtitle of your report is
a consensus study which made me chuckle
a little bit because when you get a
group of you know academics in a room
it's it's difficult to come to consensus
so I'm curious where were the dimensions
of may be constructive tension among all
of you when when writing up this report
my second question is what are your
recommendations for when students or
faculty are attending meetings run by
academic associations that are off
campus and sort of outside the
jurisdiction of any particular
university Thanks well yeah why don't I
is this microphone work
okay as I mentioned the the report is a
consensus report and the committee was
was very diverse we had basically social
scientists we had engineers and
scientists we had a few people from
industry we had college presidents and
we spent a lot of time basically looking
at the data analyzing the data trying to
come to consensus I won't say there was
yelling and screaming across the table
but almost and and ultimately we we all
came to feel very comfortable with the
report as as it was put together that
those of us who had certain things we
wanted to see happen we were satisfied
and people who wanted to say something
about the data and how it should be
acquired I think they were satisfied so
I think in the end we but it took two
years to kind of come to an agreement
and I think it was a was a very good
piece of work and I think that's what
makes the report strong is that building
that consensus so do you want to say
something about the ills yeah I just I
want to just add to what Sheila just
said which is that the foundation of
coming to consensus was evidence and at
the end of the day it is really the
evidence that allowed us to come to
consensus we are humans and so we bring
to the table various opinions and views
the question is are those opinions and
views always rooted in the best evidence
and we held ourselves extremely
accountable to that evidence and that's
why we feel very strongly about the
reports of the the recommendations the
findings and the recommendations this is
an opinion it's really based in the data
for the second part of the question
regarding off-site activity this is a
critically important area and it's why
we believe that field sites are
critically important and also
professional organizations a lot of the
professional societies are now taking on
this issue and creating a
ground rules for what happens at their
meetings so it's really an extension of
the academic institution so I think we
really need to view those as a continuum
and really work both at the
institutional level but also for the
professional societies can I ask a
question about consensus because you
made a choice about language and I think
that's often the hardest thing to get
consensus around one of the interesting
language linguist language choices that
you made was about the use of the term
civility and so I wonder if that was a
point of tension or how you came to look
more at using
civility as a sort of broader category
versus harassment or some other kinds of
phrases that we might have use abuse of
power or to focus on what we felt you
just mentioned civility is a positive
word harassment is a negative word so I
think it's a lot easier to choose the
positive word civility I think it sells
better yeah but I do need it that's a
great pickup because it we did have a
lot of discussion because I think in
some arenas that can be viewed as a
negative even though it's a positive
term it can be viewed as a negative term
and it can be viewed as somewhat term
around how are we trying to guide
behavior and I think when we came down
to it what we're really talking about
here is civility meaning a culture of
respect and how we behave towards each
other thank you to all the panelists I
was I'm a my name is Rachel Curtin and
I'm a graduate student and like I think
many PhD students I've sort of bounced
around through my time through many
different funding sources and so the the
point about departmental funding as a
way to diffuse this sort of power
relation
it really struck me and I think that's
something that would have a lot broader
impact than just diffusing that power
relationship in terms of people's sense
of security and a lot in terms of their
their funding security not not personal
safety I would it's that - it strikes me
though that that could pose certain
challenges to the way that research is
funded currently through the granting
agencies in terms of being granted to a
group and certain number of grad student
years or something like that so I'm
curious if the committee talked about
any changes in the sort of structure or
terms of actual research grants that
might have to be implemented to make
such a proposal which I would be
personally really excited about kind of
feasible at a large scale and not just
to institutions that sort of might have
the independent funding to to make that
happen well you know grant III agree
this is this is that this relationship
between mentor Manman TPI training is so
fundamental to our research structure
but it also causes some of the dynamics
as you said that are highly problematic
research grants are granted to
institutions the p i-- is part of the
institution so i'm not saying that it's
easy i don't think we believe it's easy
we actually didn't talk about the
specifics but we felt that given the
money that the money does come to
institutions that there are ways to
begin to think about some of the grant
money actually being more centralized
for the grantees when it is allocated to
grantees as opposed to being dependent
on that one-to-one relationship I thank
you so much it couldn't be more timely
my name is Hilary Robinson I was a
student here and I'm a professor in the
law school and the Department of
Sociology at Northeastern I came late so
forgive me if I'm gonna reference
Catherine MacKinnon and you already
spoke about her but it was very notable
to me that the title of this report is
the sexual harassment of women which is
very evocative of McKinnon's very
influential book the sexual harassment
of working women and you mentioned or in
several of your slides
dr. Johnson there was this reference to
the law and to the need for formal
legality in these kinds of proceedings
which is what MacKinnon who was also
love professor called for that until we
think about this as a kind of tort which
is what the harassment word means with
all respect to the idea of civility
being a kind of nicer way to get people
to engage in these conversations and I
just wonder if you could speak
specifically about your conversations
around the law I know professor Hill
you're a law professor I think that
would be illuminating for all of us
because sometimes you really do need to
push into the realm of actual litigation
which requires money and institutional
support thank you well I think one of
the things that we're learning in this
moment is that the living that
litigation has has been a necessary but
not sufficient tool for eliminating the
kind of harassment that we know is
prevalent we also know that there are
some real limitations to litigation as a
tool access to law access to legal
representation is very limited the the
legal system relies on the most
vulnerable people very often to come and
complain and we know that there are high
levels as many as much as 60% of people
will experience
retaliation and we also know that for
low-income women the amount of payoff in
terms of wages often are not high enough
to support the finding of legal
representation so those are all of the
things that we're dealing with the
dynamics and we're dealing with it
doesn't make law irrelevant but it makes
it inadequate in and what I
I believe that our recommendations the
recommendations of this volume as well
as recommendations generally are that
you know yes we need to have some new
legal strategies around sexual
harassment but we also need for work to
take place within institutions that does
not rely on even a complaint process or
a complaint getting to the level of
something that is to be litigated before
we act and I think in I would not have
chosen the word civility because I'm a
lawyer by training so I would but but I
think it is important that we change the
bar so that managers appropriately
trained can intervene before things get
to a level of a legal violation so I
think there is and we have - lawyers
don't always work well with other
systems but I think we we've got to work
together on this and to see this as a
holistic systemic problem that will be
resolved through a lot of tactics that
approaches well as you mentioned your
recommendations and definitions are
pretty broad for that very reason the
federal Department of Education
last year rescinded that infamous April
2011 Dear Colleague letter in order to
better protect the rights and interests
of the accused and I haven't heard you
say anything about how you would protect
the rights of the accused free speech in
due process so you consider those to be
antiquated concepts now I actually in in
my recommend in my presentation on the
recommendations I actually very clearly
stated that processes that were clear
and were fair to all both the accused
and the accuser should be implemented
and that there should be transparent
see of those and that we should also
consider very clear guidance around what
is it that will result from certain
behaviors so this is not a black box so
if if that wasn't clear I just want to
really make that very clear fair
processes are are very important for all
thank you I'm Judy singer I'm the senior
vice provost for faculty development and
diversity at Harvard down the street and
I want to focus on the subtitle of your
report and ask a question about your
deliberations climate culture and
consequences and I'll just abbreviate to
academia so one of the questions that
I've been having conversations with
people around is the me2 movement this
report bring to light issues of sexual
harassment generally and also in the
academy but we're also concerned about
perhaps it's the Flipboard of civility
but I'll use the word that's used
bullying and the concern that in a lot
of our academic settings well there may
be sexual harassment and I'm not making
light of it
there is also bullying and was it
bullying bullying and in in both in
terms of trainee and supervisor
relationships but also collegial
relationships staff and faculty
relationships I could go on but I think
you get the context did this come up at
all in in your deliberations as another
issue to take on which is related to but
different from the whole question of
sexual harassment so the you're
absolutely right Judy and this report is
not to meant to be a full kind of
comprehensive report on all types of
harassment we were we were really
focused on a particular charge around
sexual harassment but absolutely there
are other forms of harassment so you're
absolutely right I think it's another
body of work to be done and I and it's
worthwhile actually making another
statement we were asked very
specifically to look at sexual
harassment in women so I want to make
very
clear that that sexual minorities okay
non-conforming people actually
experienced sexual harassment at rates
that are either at the same level or
around the same level of women of color
racial and ethnic minorities so again
this report we were given a very
specific charge and and focused on that
but the other areas are critically
important slightly more general from his
held I've only spent three weeks in the
United States so far and the topic of
discussion past couple days as many of
you know it's something that relates to
what you're doing but else but on a
wider scale how do you feel that the the
conclusions of your report can be
promoted institutions of higher learning
in the United States if the media scene
has some certain parts of the media
scene have an apologetic approach
towards what is the recent findings in
relation to judge Cavanaugh and Miss
Hill will you be watching the hearing on
Monday anywhere on Monday I will be in a
session most of the day but not and not
in Washington in a session but I will
tune in as I can and I guess I do I'm
not quite clear on your first question
how is how can the findings of this
report be promoted promoted and also
accepted by institutions of higher
learning and um if there are certain
segments of the population but also
especially the media scene who are
aren't as critical of sexual harassment
as they should be as was witnessed in
the coverage of the cabinet here well I
think that the promotion of this report
has already started and I honestly the
one of the first days that it was out I
actually talked to a journalist and they
were really pleased with this report
specifically because it gives concrete
recommendations and I think if you know
I think that's going to be the best way
to report we are the best rate of
promoter to show that there are concrete
actions that can be taken and I don't
recommend and you know I don't want to
advise anybody on their promotion but I
will just say starting or leading with
the specific recommendations is I think
an effective way to communicate that
this is serious work and that it can
have real consequences because that's
what people are ready for hi my name is
Jen in and actually I came here to speak
for another I'm the speaker and
intentionally strategize so that I could
be here because I it's an honor to meet
Anita Hill but also because I work on
this issue globally for millennial
women's around the world and since this
report
I mean I'd the person who was performing
you said you were charged with the
specific question so it answered some of
my questions but I'm actually concerned
more with the title because globally I
see this problem it is rampant and it is
unbelievable and unimaginable and I
really believe we need to change that
title the sexual harassment by men
because if we're really talking about
accountability and we're talking about I
don't understand why it to me by putting
women the onus is on us and global the
young women around the world are
screaming why do we keep focusing on us
and not the perpetrator
[Music]
well let me let me say something about
that I think it was important to have a
title that is as broad as possible and
that's why I do like the climate culture
because it basically says it isn't just
a few outrageous acts it is the entire
climate and culture that women are find
themselves in so I really felt that we
needed to broaden the the tasks that we
were given rather than just focusing on
you know small things so I think and I'm
just gonna say the the focus was on
sexual harassment of women predominantly
and we say it very clearly in the report
which is predominantly by men but if you
say so I mean just technically that is
what we were asked to focus on if you
say sexual harassment by men that can be
of women which is the majority can be
but you know on for men I mean so I
think it wasn't I I get your point and
it's a very important point and we do
focus in the report on the issue that
this is predominantly male on female but
technically the title was really the
right title for the charge we were given
okay my name is Emily Neil I run the
Women's and Gender Studies program here
and I was curious I thought I heard you
say in the beginning of your
recommendations that you specifically
recommended that sexual harassment
training be done in person is that what
you said versus it's one of the it's one
of the recommendations and the early
data the data that we have to date
actually suggests that in-person
training is more effective
were there any just in terms of that
research
dude large institutions
examples of doing in-person training for
large populations so if this is one of
our recommendations actually that this
is an area we actually tried our best to
stay away from recommendations that said
we need further study because you know
there's nothing like a report that just
says you need to study it more but but
this is an area where there really is
there really is inadequate data and the
the limited data available does suggest
those things that I stated which are in
person of a particular length targeted
specifically towards different groups
having leadership present and focused on
behavior change and not on changing
beliefs that those were the
characteristics but this is really an
area that requires more more evaluation
in order to understand for example in an
institution of this size what would that
look like yeah so I think there's work
to be done
first of all thank you all my name is
Melinda Durham oh and I was just
wondering if you would have advice for
something like something I could do to
get visibility into an institution I
abra Tory I worked for a laboratory
4,000 people 13% women and just
visibility into the harassment cases
numbers and the organization is very
adamant that it should be handled only
on a case-by-case basis where there's
just no awareness anything advice like
anything I could lean on to try to get a
survey or like when that's not allowed I
assume from what you say that you're a
graduate student is that correct no I
work I have been very impressed with the
Association of Women graduate students
and the association of undergraduates
and I think various groups can form
people can sort of form groups and join
and discuss and that group becomes
supportive and it becomes effective and
you can move the issue along yeah and it
it gets the people involved who and they
will learn more so I would recommend
forming some groups and talking about it
and trying to move the ball down the
road yeah hi I'm Mike bono and I'm a
postdoc here and I want to thank you all
for coming and presenting so my question
is I remember when I was in grad school
there was this clear and pervasive
message of like if you crossed a
professor directly whether it was your
advisor or another professor or like you
know you were the victim of harassment
or here is the bystander that you
crossed a professor directly like
they they would ruin your career and
there is this and I think that we have
this like it's challenge in academia
more this idea of like you know a good
word from the right person can make your
career in a bad word can break it so my
question is as like as researchers in
like it's research community how can we
change this culture to make it easier
for people to come forward in cases of
harassment well I mean this is it this
is at the heart of some of the
recommendations which is the fear of
retaliation and until we really begin to
change the culture this is not going to
be a one bite each because that's not
the way to change it and that actually
has been our approach right we get a bad
actor and a person who has violated the
policy and then okay we deal with that
and then it's over until the next one so
it's really not until the culture
changes I'm not saying you don't have to
do those things but it's not really
until the culture changes that we begin
to change the behavior and this issue
about the fear of retaliation is a real
one and I think that that's one that
again from the very top all the way down
to colleagues and it's going to take
colleague to colleague pressure as well
and responsibility and that's the way I
really think we're gonna begin to change
the culture so that there isn't this
fear and to think about again defusing
that power relationship which is when
you are fully dependent on one person
and you know that can be either in a
class obviously that's one way but
usually it's in a research environment
that can be highly problematic so who
are the others around you in some
network of mentors that you can rely on
to to help in these situations so as
what is the institution just form a
community talk to other professors talk
to other students go to the
and share information with people who in
a fundamental way share your values but
I have to say I really do understand
your question because I've been on
committees hiring committees and we get
letters of recommendation and we look at
the letters and we say oh this person
studied with X why isn't there a letter
from X in the file and retaliation can
be overt it can be covered it can
inmates it and so what we have to do is
not only question the power defuses but
we've got to question our systems for
evaluating people for jobs whether or
not we are opening up the door really
for this kind of behavior that allows
war or enables those kinds of power
abuses and so and I think that that
there it's more than just burden on
students we have to think about how that
I demyx work and whether or not in our
hiring process is a decision we are
contributing to it and I do think that
the leadership can be very helpful and
by no means I agree with you
Anita this is not the job of a student
it is the job of leadership and
leadership at all levels and you know
this this point about how we make
decisions is critically important in
addition to again getting to and we're
hiring this idea of the way that we
protect her a sir's with various
confidentiality agreements again and how
we pass people from institution to
institution we really do have to stop hi
my name is Cara I'm a graduate student
thank you guys so much so the report in
what you talked about today there's a
lot of discussion about diagnosing the
problem and recommendations for fixing
the problem but to me a lot of it feels
reliant on
getting people to care in the first
place didn't want to participate in
these things so I mean just as like two
examples you know at the highest levels
I think a lot of people in this room
probably maybe saw the documentary on
Netflix I hope this is the right name
it's called hunting ground which I think
was really shocking that showed kind of
the extreme levels that universities go
to to cover these you know some of these
like more severe sexual assault cases so
that they don't ever get too light and
then you know on like the lowest level
on a peer-to-peer level you know I think
there's like a lot of women in this room
probably more women than men it seems
like and I don't think women outnumber
men at this in this university and I
think with my own personal experiences
I'm involved in a lot of personal things
with you know trying to start you know
more at grassroots or whatever movements
to support women but also support
students in general and it seems like in
though my experience with that it's also
women dominated so how do you get people
my peers that are men at the lowest
levels and how do you get universities
at the highest levels to care about this
and where does that fit into this report
so I'm just going to talk I'm going to
begin by the highest levels which is
part of what we are doing with this
report is really focusing on the highest
level University College presidents and
others and positions of power how do we
get this word out to them and then how
do we get them to start working with
each other because there's nothing like
peer pressure right this has really got
to come from those in power it's not the
responsibility the foot you know I mean
obviously the at the lowest level
there's work to be done but we've got to
get the highest level engaged the
organizations that need to be engaged I
don't know how many people saw that the
triple a triple a s Peggy Hamburg is the
president they just announced that they
will actually take action to remove
members who have been found in violation
of sexual harassment policies and the
National Academies of science
engineering and
or looking at this as well I think that
this is the kind of change that we
really need to begin to begin seeing
Francis Collins came out with a
statement either yesterday or two days
ago about harassment at the NIH it's a
good statement not strong enough but
it's a step in the right direction so I
think there's a National Science
Foundation and what it plans there's got
to be a movement at the top around
changing the way we do business to make
some of the things that you are
discussing quite frankly not only are
they illegal to you know cover up that
kind of of action but just generally not
done in institutions MIT and I believe
what you guys said about protecting
people from retaliation or removing the
fear of retaliation would make a
phenomenal difference um did you guys
put or what thought our ideas did you
have about protecting people in such a
like social media heavy environment so
one it's a very good point and I may not
answer your question directly but I want
to give you an example of where it's
very clear women do fear retaliation and
often will not report what mechanisms
can we use to actually get women to
identify the instances of harassment
that have occurred without actually
coming forward until they are ready to
come forward so there for example is is
a program called Callisto and it was
started out on the west coast now a
number of colleges and universities use
it and what it is it's the reporting
system that allows a target to go in and
actually timestamp and identify an
incident and can do it anonymous
and you can actually have access to data
to understand whether or not there are
others reporting and it is there in the
records so that and until you are ready
to actually report so it's a way of
identifying allowing you to kind of see
what else is happening but that's a way
of that's one way of allowing women to
record data without going that next step
again until you're ready and you know
it's not perfect but it's actually been
been adopted by a number of places and
is having significant success it's just
one example hi my name is Sarah
Sutherland I'm a grad student I mean my
question you've talked a lot about what
you can do to change the culture but
what happens when someone does come
forward and how can a community best
support them when that does happen and
that's sort of relevant to me this week
because I went to the same high school
as Christine Paisley Ford and sort of
our alumni network has been reeling and
signing letters of support around this
and so how should we best deal with that
well the first thing I would say is one
and I think I speak n with this
reporting is an act of courage and we
should we should support those who
report that's the first thing second if
there are incidents of sexual harassment
in which the target does not want to be
public with reporting but goes to a
person to share the information is not
ready to come forward then we really
have to be pretty active in providing
support whether or not that person wants
to be public in reporting and they are a
series of supports that have to do with
with mental health healthcare social
services etc so I think that there are a
number of ways that we need to both
honor and support targets of
hi I'm Nick Roth Walker and I'm a grad
student here course a lot of the
recommendations that you make in the
report require like a significant
commitment from the institutions to
challenge themselves and do a lot of
things that would seem to be against the
current interests of the institution
like damaging their image or like
sanctioning members of the research
community how do you like propose that
we enforce these recommendations against
institutions that often have more power
than I know that I can describe in this
time yeah I mean I could could sort of
take that on I mean art when we got to
the point in the report where we sort of
understood what the findings were we
sort of sat back and we said okay what's
the solution and the first word that
comes to mind is leadership and you have
to start there you have to start with
leadership with a commitment on the part
of leadership to the values that we have
laid out and so you're talking
presidents Provost's Dean's I just
kidding just kidding Marty Dean's
department heads people who are leaders
in the community that share common
values and they can make make those
values more public and and then the rest
of the community will gain confidence
that this is a an institution that
values the values that we've been
talking about and so that's really where
we started and then we got quite
specific okay what should fellow federal
agencies do well what about the law and
all these other things but it all began
with the whole question of leadership
and I think that's probably where the
recommendations begin
is the responsibility of academic
institutions to have a safe welcoming
civil environment to support students
and everything else below that are
specifics that that one needs to work
out but I mean it really starts there so
I just want to add one thing because the
question becomes so cool holds the
leader right the top leader accountable
well you know we do have bosses and
they're called boards of trustees at MIT
you have an executive committee and you
know those people also have to be held
responsible because then they hold the
leadership responsible these are issues
that need to be discussed and reported
on openly transparently
and and so it isn't just the leader
there is the leader reports to somebody
and we need to also be talking to that
level of leadership which really has
kind of the ultimate power yeah and I
would agree in an ideal world that would
work but very often we know that the
bosses of the boss are more conservative
about these issues and more protective
of the institutional reputation than
even our the president Oh
and so we have thing you have to look at
external levers you know the last few
years it's been the Department of
Education let's push that lever
not so much anymore but but there are
lumps
I mean alums now have significant power
to influence the changes it's you know
right to initiate and instigate changes
and and maybe not change the minds or
the values but to reinforce the work
that the leaders are trying to take on
and maybe getting pushback from
different sources so I think that there
are a number of ways but on another
level you have to convince institutional
leaders that it it is in their best
interest to address these problems in
this moment in the world today because
institutional reputation can be lost by
one lawsuit that reveals what is
happening and if a lawsuit happens all
kinds of of discovery can happen and so
it is no longer tenable to say that
you're protecting yourself by not being
transparent and you know at the very
heart of this report really is a call
for transparency so I think a lot of
things need to come together to be to be
sure and you know the other thing that
you have is students students can
protest and you didn't get make noise
and believe me they make more of a
difference than we've been
I think they sometimes think they have
and one other I just wanted to add one
more lever because I think Anita that
was I mean it's a very important
statement which is that is exactly why
we made the recommendations on funders
if you really want a lever funders your
research funding is a critical one so
that's another aspect of it so we have
to more people at the at the mics and
we're going to take these two questions
and then now we're gonna be able to wrap
up thanks again for the talk one thing
that struck me in the presentation was
that I think someone briefly mentioned
that there you know institutions have
tried to implement policies that reduce
sexual harassment but there is no
statistically significant decrease in
sexual harassment so how can we be sure
that institutions will implement
policies that are actually meaningful
and not just checking the boxes like
they did in the past
well that's the whole that is I mean
you're you're at the heart of what we're
attempting to do which is that a lot of
the approach in the past has been one
that has been purely legalistic avoiding
risk checking the boxes and that really
does not do anything for changing the
culture and changing behavior and we
have the data to support that so I think
this really is about kind of moving
moving away from that mentality to a
more comprehensive approach Thanks hello
my name is Ashley Blum I'm a grad
student over in the business school
wanted to thank you all for taking the
time to share your thoughts today and I
also want to take an opportunity to
thank everyone here for all of their
questions and insight I if I'm
understanding kind of the trends of this
what I feel is that we're all struggling
with the kind of the rubber meeting the
road we have all of these great ideas
but it's a difficult to kind of get them
implemented and so one of the things
that I actually wanted to offer was in
the spirit of students making noise a
bit of a solution here and so at the
business school I am part of a group
called breaking the mold and in February
we're hosting a hack for inclusion and
so this is geared towards trying to
combat bias and our schools communities
and in our jobs so we're looking for a
broader involvement within the academic
community and that also the Boston
surrounding areas so if you're
interested please please take a look at
our website which is breaking the mold
MIT and and let us know so thank you
your time and later
[Music]
so I just wanted to wrap up by saying
thank you to Sheila to Anita and Paula
for leading this really thoughtful
insightful and I would even say hopeful
discussion you are demonstrating the
kind of leadership that your report
calls for that is so essential to
eradicating sexual harassment in
academia so through your hope your hard
work you are offering all of higher ed
it very importantly an actionable
roadmap to follow and also a call to
action to answer we're really grateful
for your example and for your dedication
and so the audience thank you so much
for caring about these issues for
engaging with us and for being committed
to finding the solutions we urgently
need at the end of the day every one of
us and we heard this today has a role to
play in contributing to the culture
changes that this report calls for by
being here today
you're sending a clear message that
together we can make things better so
thank you for sharing this
responsibility with all of us here at
MIT and across higher education and
thank you again for taking part in this
vital discussion
you